hmm welcome to another installment of
mask Monday for people who think that's
sacrilegious wait a minute
just watch the entire show and that's
even Brendon from the not a member of
the clergy yeah he was not offended and
the outfit was very cheap yeah and it's
dry ice um guess it's not really it was
a safety hazard so we would never put a
Cardinal at risk no because we can never
find a cardinal to set foot in the
studio nope so this is continuing audio
aid is here Gerald a quarter black carat
continuing on the sort of rhett and Link
saga
received a quite a bit of response
letters and slash comments only actually
writes physical letters but it's mainly
just anthrax letter I open it and I just
aim it in the general direction of
Brennan go like fairy dust you just
don't appreciate a good gift more so
that I don't like being surprised link a
little bit and I want to be clear very
much appreciate rhett and Link what they
do
I can appreciate their position that
they're stepping out I do think it takes
some courage to talk about their job of
abandoning of faith and their crisis of
faith doing my best to keep this really
as brand friendly as possible which
brings me to the question this is brand
friendly or even sort of mainstream
audience friendly something the idea of
that something that Christians should
value at all is there a biblical
prescription as it applies to living
your life so that others around you like
you let me know what you think
popularity making sure that you're
polite that people like you because
you're nice is that something that is a
value inherent to the Christian faith
and if so where does it sort of take
precedence over other values and this of
course is we thought it was over after
the last Mass Monday and then Rhett and
Link's angry I believe lesbian producer
it's not relevant other than the fact
that that's probably a huge portion
while she's angry at me specific yes to
say this is the change my mind meme and
that's steven crowder or as i like to
call him Steven pieces Crowder podcast
her at TCU who sat outside with a sign
that said male privilege is a myth
change my mind and the meme is used to
convey strong hot takes on topics that
are actually important or completely
unimportant okay
let's see a few examples and I do
appreciate rhett and Link avoiding it
you know ring yeah link with the woman
Rhett with the lastly it's okay for me
laughing I'm not even on a size don't
worry you won't your views are safe
which exists it kind of a point that I
wanted to talk about this is sort of a
chant that we hear quite a bit from sort
of a mantra and you were talk about this
audio way so feel free to chime in in
nature rhett and Link they continually
talk and it seems to be a value that is
very important to them personally as
well as professionally and that's the
idea of being popular being brand
friendly there you go we know we're kind
of the poster boys of the trending page
in sort of the why are these guys always
trending back that question because it
isn't because our videos get if you look
at the training page most videos will
have more views than what we've got up
there right but I think that it's not
because we upload at the same time every
single day am you today and you don't
really have to be subscribed to know
that it takes off really really quickly
and I think the algorithm just
interprets it as a lot of people are
interested in this video even if it's
our good mythical more which is our sort
of like second Channel show after the
show that may get to the trending is so
I think it's just based on it gets
thrown into the system oh yeah Rhett
link their brand safe put them up there
that's the other thing I think I don't
know but I think that there's some sort
of a whitelisting who where it's racist
you have a fight eligibility why on the
train stage based purely on just brand
friendliness mm-hmm you know
that's what they care about the most
right yeah they got to get the brands
involved and if they know consistently I
mean those sevens 100 carat and we'll
get to that anyone know especially over
that track record there's that they can
trust that okay we're gonna we're I'm
gonna do anything to invite backlash
from brands short short short and now
you might hear that in context and you
might hear it at first feeling you know
moaning like Oh being brand saved but
that's not first off I appreciate their
I guess candor like maybe the YouTube
trending is actually curated by people
could be perhaps a white listing of
brand friendly as though they've never
heard of the Vox at popular right or
yours truly despite calling me a piece
of which I'm okay with
I'm glad I think this comes down you
know we need to be honest with our
audience of course the turning page is
not what it used to be it's not based on
most popular most viewed most discussed
and of course there is a white list and
there a shadow band u2 has been very
clear about that they've talked about
that and mentioning me by name at the
recode conference so I want to make sure
that we're very clear on this if rhett
and Link would like to learn more about
that we have plenty of documentation 1t
but to go back to the point that it may
originally seem and this is what I do
want to focus on in a biblical
perspective because they sort of tie in
there their ideas beforehand of how they
live their life into a biblical
perspective and why they left which is
just I would disagree with because I
don't think it's a biblical perspective
I were talking about brand friendly and
the idea of appealing to a mass audience
regardless of what requires that what is
required to be appealing but here you go
I think this is another clip just so you
have some context echoing again this
sort of overall sentiment in their
content at the YouTube live event yeah
and it was the first time we all got
together I was you know I said we felt
like outsiders because we weren't we
weren't connecting with the community in
the way that a lot of creators were
I also felt I think we I know what that
feel
fundamental and I hope admit if you had
an interaction with us and I'm you know
what maybe maybe what maybe you remember
but I had this thought that like people
can tell that we're different and we
would usually say that in a good ways
like people can tell that we're
different and that's us being a witness
for us having a relationship with Jesus
okay Jesus but it was also this people
can tell that we're different because
we're we're uptight
I think we're judgmental people think
that it's that oh they moved to LA and
they got liberal you know they gave up
their faith yes you know well you could
also believe it on YouTube because many
years before it's like I mean in a very
good way it expanded well I don't blame
it on YouTube I blame it on the people
who YouTube gonna YouTube but I didn't
place the blame squarely on the
shoulders and this is also a biblical
principle of personal responsibility in
being judged for one's own actions
trying to appeal to the overlords at
YouTube I know what they're talking
about as far as as far as feeling on the
outside I've never once been to a VidCon
as far on the outside as you could
possibly be yeah I'm that original
Disney cartoon Mickey Mouse with the
hobo out and giving dinner no one lets
me in oh they just spoiler alert the
door so you want to come in take my cash
safe and there you go we won't run the
ads that we wrote for you right and I
think this is important we'll go back to
some more clips a little bit later on
this is that you know that you've heard
the term probably argumentum ad populum
or appeal to popularity it's an it first
up before we get to the spiritual it's
an intellectual fallacy it is yes in
talking about how this matters or how
this is important or how maybe people
didn't like us because we were uptight
and judgmental myself I make judgments
certainly not uptight you can see just
the the wardrobe choices that I've made
on this program out of
because by the way this shrunk this
shirts no no did no barbell nipples it's
just a drunk you can see it's an XL
maybe we can zoom on it but I feel great
Qing I sold the XL little on the large
shirts from Armani and so's in JCPenney
yeah I just have man breasts so is there
outside of the idea intellectually that
really you can't use that as an argument
at all how many people receive you a
certain way that doesn't necessarily
mean that they're right there can be the
majority of any group any country any
historical class and they can be wrong
we've seen that time and time again so
YouTube can be wrong and I would argue
they are spiritually is there any
biblical basis for this and I wanted to
talk about this what are the dangers of
basing your faith or even your lifestyle
around appealing to popularity yeah
anyway yeah what they also use that same
argument when they're talking about the
church needing to accept I believe gay
marriage and things like lip yeah we do
yeah
so it the their argument at populum is
essentially their world view the world
view is an appeal to Authority go ahead
no that's all we'll go back to that clip
and we have some verses here to get into
because I think this is something that
this sort of I've always said it does a
great disservice unfortunately to
Christianity one you whitewash it a lot
of people saying oh yes if you just say
God is just God is love no no God of
course loves everyone right as
Christians and again this is Mass Monday
so for people who are angry atheists a
see you in the comments section so you
can tell us why you think we're wrong
but God loves all of his children we are
all his children but that does not mean
that God has only love that that's the
only value that matters discernment
matters obviously judgment does matter
and the idea that you should be loved by
everyone is of course untrue well and
they danced around some topics here
going back through the two clips that we
played the first one was dancing around
the obvious elephant in the room of yeah
I don't know really why our videos show
up on the trending page as much as they
do I mean
I mean ignorance is bliss I guess you
might feel it useful to have a larger
channel that basically says Christianity
is wrong and right
LGBTQ past pastors and I but I don't
understand why they're so friendly to us
I'll take a wild guess well in the
second the second video real quick he
said that they had 1,700 videos of a
track record that that showed that they
were going to be brand friendly and and
I don't say this out of anger towards
them but in this conversation that's
been started are you telling me over
1,700 videos you've never taken a stand
that was unpopular you have tried to
confess recently unfortunately in
calling me a drink they were surprised
that they get up not being not being
seen as champions that a good guy had
the little guy
what up consequence are you talking
about over 1,700 videos that doesn't
make someone uncomfortable or mad at you
pedestrian or encounter I'm just there's
a place for that as well right this is
my problem that I've always had with the
watering down of Christian usually God
is love God loves his children of course
and you can he's all about God above God
is all of the things but it's really
easy and this is why you need an
intellectual basis in your faith it's
really easy if you say well man I don't
care about all the rest that stuff god
is love and then it's easy for atheist
and at one point you know when people
really were using the Hitchens sorry
crisp regions not Peter tonight this
region's arguments like well God has
killed more people than all governments
that's absolutely true if you read the
Old Testament it's an r-rated film and
that's not because God doesn't love but
that's because God is also just and God
understands that certain certain times
in history require certain appropriate
levels of punishment so just
whitewashing Christianity with the Rob
Bell or even the prosperity gospel it's
too easy to poke holes in and
unfortunately I think that some of that
might have been the basis of a lot of
Rhett and Link's faith because that's a
lot of young Christians and then that's
a really easy transfer to sort of moral
ambiguity situational ethics which is
where we see them now well and I think
that it comes out of the whole God is
love thing which by the way would you
want to serve a god that was unjust that
didn't punish wickedness that didn't
reward you know doing the things that he
asks you to do and and there's a really
quick answer to this
no nobody around the world well that
you're gonna because it's not that was
gonna be surprised like a patent
right well think about it this way who's
gonna go into a Dom DeLuise and print
out I mean so it's made this argument
you don't have to teach a child the
stealing their toy is a bad thing right
you sense unjustice right when an unjust
situation occurs it offends you even as
a child as a toddler before you're
taught anything you know that that
someone else steals your toy
unfortunately children can steal other
people's toys and they don't feel but
you took yeah but I want this one yeah
exactly yeah we're evil little my otters
so I'd like to get into four kind of
focusing on this idea that is there a
biblical basis right at all to wanting
to please as many people as possible or
being as brand friendly as possible I
think we have a couple of verses here
Gerald a few or audio wait if you wanna
buddy let's go for it yeah so Luke 6:26
woe to you and all people speak well of
you for so their fathers did to the
false prophets pretty rough stuff
Galatians 1:10 for MI now seeking the
approval of man or of God or am I trying
to please man if I were still trying to
please man I would not be a servant of
Christ let me have Gerald read the other
one could see the nineteen if the world
hates you know that it has hated me
before it hated you fewer of the world
the world would love you as its own but
because you are not of the world but I
chose you out of the world therefore the
world hates you right and I want to be
clear this doesn't mean that you should
that if you're a douchebag than I will
stone go get him strive to be hated but
here's a good example Christ did not
strive to be hated no but steadfast in
what he believed the Pharisees Sadducees
the ruling class of the day and by the
way while we're talking about this we'll
come back to YouTube you cannot name me
a government or a ruling class more
powerful than the companies that are
Facebook alphabet Amazon Apple ya know
right now you can Twitter I mean they
kind of like hey that's too no Jack
Dorsey well the truth is and they all
come and they are and here's what's also
matters they are also enabling and they
are also accessories to other
governments outside of the United States
oh yeah and the news will get into China
a little bit but Jesus offended the
ruling class it wasn't just religious it
wasn't just pious religiosity right it
was effectively a socio-political ruling
class with the sit Pharisee said she
didn't go in it's like hey your robe is
funny it sucks where'd you get that at
gays are
Pharisees I'm just joking Nicodemus
you're alright no I didn't do that no
and he said I am that's about as
offensive as you can get when Jesus said
no this is this is absolutely what I
believe I'm not going to change it and
inherently that created a rift that came
with hatred of some not all well he knew
that truth would divide people and so
that's why I'm one of the verses we
didn't quote this one here but he says I
didn't come to unite but to divide he
wasn't saying like I've come to be a
division among he whos came I came to
give you truth and I know that truth is
going to divide you guys because people
are not going to accept it right and
it's gonna make them very angry I'm not
gonna do it in an unloving way but I am
going to be truthful I'm gonna take a
stand so you're saying that crucifixion
was kind of the first D monetization
that really was yeah yeah going back to
if if you've made that much content and
have made some nothing that people
disagree with or that rubs brands the
wrong way then you don't have any
standards yeah and if there's that much
content are you is like Taco Bell your
ultimate morality standard whether
they're gonna monetize your video that's
a silly way of viewing bulletin you can
just say it you can just say look we
want to make money and so we don't take
stands on issues Yeah right you can just
be very honest with who you are maybe
they maybe they don't have stands on
issues so I maybe they don't have any
fundamental worldview that they're
willing to stand up for and so they're
fine they're totally brain friendly I
don't know we just know that they aren't
taking any stand but they were
Christians before they went to but they
weren't taking seleya right as
Christians right that's what I'm saying
like if they were very much the whole
got agape Los Angeles Christianity a
brand of love which again is more easily
transferable like you know your your
rewards points with no blackout dates
it's feel good god is love is it much
more easily transferable to you know
what I just want to make everyone feel
good by not offending anybody yeah and
that also so happens to conveniently
land you on the trending page and land
you in the good graces of YouTube by the
way that's also a lot of policy the idea
that well Taco Bell you this is also
sung when your time up appeal being
brand friendly you're talking about
appealing to brands that through the
selection process inherently share one
worldview you want to tell right that's
you know that Smith & Wesson that I
don't know to take take your pick of a
litany of these companies wouldn't want
to run ads on usually they're excluded
they're not allowed therefore brand
friendly is appealing to the brands who
are allowed by widget scheme yeah and
and Rhett has a medium are several
medium articles one of them is against
guns and he has others that are so that
are basically just pure white guilt
stuff so it's like it really you again
why else is white listed yeah you speak
a certain way if he's gonna speak on
issues that has to be about this it
doesn't it can't necessarily be
monetized on YouTube but right it's
within the whole paradigm and here's
something to I want to be clear about
it's totally fine if someone that has a
point of view that we don't share for
example if he ain't a firearm that's
fine
and you have a discussion about that but
at a certain point when you say hold on
a second I have spoken out against
firearms I have clearly spoken out
against the church for not record most
churches for not recognizing same-sex
marriage or allowing gay people in
positions of authority by the way same
thing with promiscuous members of the
church on that life your cohabitating at
my church if your cohabitating with your
girlfriend you're not allowed to be a
pastor you know ought to be a marriage
counselor it's not allowed that's so I
want to be really clear they spoke
they've taken delight issues this will
all show our branding marks afterward
that we got in front of Molech but he's
clearly taken some stands yeah is there
ever a history one you were a Christian
or an atheist or agnostic ever a track
record of taking a stand that may not be
brand friendly in other words it's no
risk to say I'm against firearms yes no
risk to say allow LGBTQA a IP in the
church but I've got to imagine that
every single person from far-left
Marxist communist to far-right and Arcis
have some views that are unpopular or
not brand friendly I can't imagine
anyone going through seventeen hundred
videos without something that isn't
brent friendly whether it's the pope
whether it's the imam of peace whether
it's our channel whether it's philip
defranco unless it is by design
inconsequential yeah and I think it's
just it shows a bit of a
lack of awareness to the the system that
they are playing in it maybe they know
exactly what they're doing or that they
may be just a little naive about it but
you can't go through that entire process
and say well we haven't ever done
anything that would make brands not want
to be a part of us or see backlash and
you need to be honest with seconds what
we've done has been so far to the left
that nobody cares that we've taken those
stances we haven't taken stances that
are conservative right that would get
advertisers mad at us just be and I
would be much happier to see people to
say that anti-authoritarian will get
back middle of the road conserve China
for their human rights file right yeah
you can call out you can call out
right-to-work states how about seconds
but you can't call out China for human
rights violations actly you can call out
Michigan for be the 25th state to go
right to work no problem not at all you
have an ad run on there for some kind of
a non-profit escape but you cannot say
hey by the way who is effectively
propaganda arm of China and they refuse
to actually recognize any kind of
sovereignty from Taiwan right so why
don't we look it's not just right and
left there also is a component of right
and wrong here and my point is if we
want to talk about common ground the
division that is sewed is is often
because of YouTube and because of big
text sort of acting as though there's
this brand friendly like this is the
discourse that's allowed in in a civil
society but the fact is whole second
flock rightful coffee right they
sponsored the show because they want to
go against the grain because they don't
want to sponsor those points of view
right but they have to come to us
directly because a lot of these
companies can't just get in the same
YouTube branding program that is not a
fact that's not an argument for a
foundational moral worldview and I would
argue that historically that proves to
actually be far more dangerous because
there needs to be someone to speak up
for people who can't speak for
themselves and I'm not just talking with
LGBTQA IP but I'm talking about people
who are actually oppressed we can get
back to China and we can get back to
everyone who's been demonetised for
example on YouTube hey you have a big
channel
what about documentarians who are
liberal who after the Vox apocalypse can
no longer make money a lot of people
need other folks to champion their cause
and that is your duty if you have a
platform we try to do it here sometimes
we fail I think we should probably go
did you want to say so just gonna say
it's it's not just brands in general
it's just the brands that have been
chosen by YouTube right so there is a
selection process and that's
issue but also it's not just brands it's
there seems to be that their worldview
is shaped a lot by just people who use
YouTube yes I think that's actually the
next and this is actually so here's
another clip where um and honestly like
I say I say this with it with a heavy
heart and you know listen obviously I
know I make fun of people a whole lot
more I'm trying to avoid doing that with
rhett and Link just because I would love
to obviously speak with them and and
I'll make fun of them some other day for
things that are relatively
inconsequential but I don't want to
twist the knife if they feel alienated
because of their worldview so yeah just
feeling like you're saying a different
side of me it's cuz I'm I'm being good
they couldn't be this is so sad more
obsessed with what other people think
about them that is the basis because
that also determines how they view
themselves if you don't believe me and
you don't think this is sad here's
another clip first thing you do when you
wake up roll over pick up my phone and
build my self image from the YouTube
comments
first thing I do when I wake up is roll
over see if retz
texted me because his self-image is
being shattered by YouTube comments yep
now let me be really clear here by the
way because you could lob this criticism
at me when I wake up and actually I will
say when I wake up I try and do my
devotionals first and often make some
coffee trying to take some time and I do
I do pray because that's a big part of
big part of what makes me me but even
the first thing I do when I go into my
email or I go into our drive to look at
show Maps and research the last thing in
my mind is hey what did people think
about me in other words you know I don't
read the comments alright you guys have
instruct I'm not supposed to because it
can because specifically this can happen
what I am doing is going okay what
inaccuracies in justices or need-to-know
information do I have to work on today
to best serve our audience it's not how
can the audience best serve my ego or
determine my moral worldviews that I'm
still under the brand friendly umbrella
and make the youtube trending list so
there's a big difference between wanting
to do your job well wanting to serve
your audience well and wanting to
shape-shift in order in order to frankly
maximize the the pat on the back ego
stroked that your audience provides you
which is why it's sad to me because
that'll always
be fleeting yeah it's never gonna lead
you to a good place and historically
we've seen that just following after a
popular opinion it doesn't normally lead
to a more edifying more loving more
accepting more truth centered world or a
freer world at all and so there's just
you know saying in latin vox populi vox
Dei sorry for saying Vox I apologize I
hope it doesn't do anything but
basically I'm Rambo no but it basically
this concept that the voice of the
people is the voice of God right and
that seems to be where read and link
might be leaning right because they've
talked about how they've you know we
went through the deconstructing their
faith and that's what started all this
obviously and please don't use a day I
know what I'm using their word I'm
quoting I refuse
they left their faith yeah and so this
this has kind of become their worldview
in place of that because they've said to
haven't gone to anything else they're
not now Buddhists or Taoists or whatever
you know they're just kind of out there
and so really it's like well what's
popular what is what are the people
saying and I think there's a strong
point to be made here look there's
nothing wrong with being successful
there's nothing wrong with being rich
course not there's nothing wrong with
being popular there's something wrong
with seeking these things as your
priority right anytime you place
anything above god no matter what it is
right you can place family above god and
that would be a problem you can do a lot
of things but that's where things get
out of whack and i think that's what
we're not and i want to go to waitis but
i haven't felt that as a kid one of my
favorite christmas films of all time as
Muppet Christmas Carol and it's actually
despite the Marley brothers because I
think it's fit in the hecklers as the
money yeah despite that it's actually
one of the most accurate renditions of
Christmas Carol yeah that I've seen but
there is a song where Michael Cain says
if well he sings but it's really like
Pierce Brosnan oh oh measure of a man
you simply count is Fred that's yeah
yeah and I said the kid growing simply
count as friends and as a kid it
bothered me yeah on a second Jesus had a
few friends and a lot of people who
wanted him dead yeah so you've gotta
count friends as well as enemies and
some people have more friends and so
they'll have more enemies and it doesn't
mean that they're necessarily morally
right or wrong but you shouldn't to me
someone saying that's the metric of a
man how many friends um bothered me as a
kid
well and and God's standards the
convenient one convenient thing about
them is that they don't change right and
that the voice of the people is always
changing and so if cons if your standard
is always changing that's exhausting
right but God's God's standard again is
consistent and it does actually lead the
flourishing it leads to healthy
psychology and all the way that's a
really good point I want to say because
we also have a clip specifically from
rhettandlink for that I find it really
interesting that some people are making
that argument and one thing I saw said
it's too late for rhettandlink mostly
because of this LGBTQ thing once they've
gone there well it's too late for them
and I'm like can't you see that you guys
have lost this argument the history is
going to leave you behind you know
because some conservative right
denominations a hundred years from now
no no one except these like a fringe
cult is gonna be anti LGBT in a hundred
years it's just if you just look at
history and the way things progress
culturally eventually the church says ok
we'll incorporate that too because if we
don't we're going to die but I think
because the church is being really slow
it's kind of causing an existential
crisis and a crisis of just the way that
they see survival and the young people
are just saying I'm out I'm not gonna be
a part of this Hollis I mean if young
people are the young people like you
that doesn't cause someone like me to
say I'm out from the Bible because guess
what it doesn't force me to relook at
the Bible at all the idea of progress
first off progress changes and change
directions progress you can look at
times where we were far more left and
far more talent even you can just look
at what people don't realize this if you
look at fashion throughout the United
States so for example we think of the
50s or as a really conservative here you
can look at that that was hype early
sexualized were enhanced the hips and
the looks impressed I don't know what's
going on with a pointy cone and the
sixties in the 70s where we change that
reaction we made men look like women and
men wore bell-bottoms you know lighter
tops because it was kind of a feminist
revolution then you look at the 80s
where it went the other we had shoulder
pads and all of a sudden we went to
women looking more masculine
you know these things change standards
of modesty change the idea of LGBTQA a
changes as you can see by the acronym
and for the first time in 10 years a
more negative point of view this year
than last year
now the LGBTQA AIP movement so young
people aren't just going to tune out
because something is popular young
people may turn out if they hold the
world view that rhettandlink did which
wasn't the theological e and
foundationally ii and keep in mind that
this entire movement started with 12
guys on a mountain so today there's and
it wasn't it wasn't the like
compromising with the surrounding
cultural the whole thing grow right so
the growth and change things like that
aren't it's not an issue of compromised
really the only way to move forward and
to grow is by being faithful right he'll
kind of look like a skull to you I'm not
sure I think you're gonna be killed on
it I think that's gonna be great for the
religion yes just picture it this is
gonna catch on this will be a moment
yeah he said like in 200 years of Fringe
cult won't believe these things what
thousand years right but you all sort of
miss misperceptions is also important
where he was like in the earlier video
we've talked about this where he talked
about Michael Buckley - what about guy
yeah that was his thing so I do think if
you interpreted that you were supposed
to hate someone because they were gay
that was not at all a biblical
interpretation and if you're trying to
say that won't be in the church 100
years from now what's not in the church
now yeah it's not in the church now it's
never there have been bastardization of
it but it's never been mainstream
theology in the church that you are to
hate anyone no and I had but I don't I
don't think that he's just saying that I
think he's saying that it will be openly
celebrated and accept it as normal and
not sin right and I think that's the
problem that we we have what kind of
faith do we have if it just bends to our
social will as time goes on right we
have nothing we have something that can
kind of move around and go well well at
some point thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's wife is gonna probably have
to go out of style because you'll just
be you know some random church and
you'll die right thing to Utah is that's
in style
this is the thing like some places
you've got to have an understanding that
God's Word is what it is and you can
think what you want about it but you
have to be honest about what it says so
if he says well churches are just gonna
have to change well you're not saying
churches will have to change let's be
very clear you're saying God will have
to change yes and I wanted to this is
also why the watering down of the faith
no I think someone said this is I can't
claim credit if someone said you keep
watered-down medicine and then be
surprised when it doesn't work yeah
that's why I think it's really wrong
when you have a lot of preachers who go
out there and they draw the line at
LGBTQA AIP but they don't go out there
and actively speak against you know
living with someone before you're
married material you may not be but but
as it's it's not a part of the Christian
faith we are not to accept that as as
something to be esteemed at the very
least now doesn't mean we don't accept
those people doesn't me that those
people aren't welcome to George's
percent a heroin addict a heroin I'm not
comparing all gabled here on it but a
heroin addict someone who dress a
crossdresser and transsexual and gay
person and person who is just living
with his girlfriend for seven years
she's just a piece of paper baby they
are all welcome to church none of them
none of them are welcome in positions of
authority to counsel others well Indiana
we need to draw that line before it gets
to something that is culturally popular
like the movement du jour of the LGBTQ
and IP well it's the line off before
Jennifer Aniston adopts what is it
Rachael and Friends decide just wants to
have a baby without a dad yes that's
wrong yeah for some reason it's more
acceptable to some Christians because
she's attracted fresh and Jesus actually
set the standard for this like he was he
was actually accused or he was a 'cold
essentially because he would be often
found around sinners prostitutes and
people who needed and he basically made
the comment it's not the well that need
the doctor it's the sick like the people
that are sick is those are the people so
you don't shun these people groups from
church you just call sin sin that's it
you just say hey guys God says that
these are the things that we shouldn't
be doing to experience life in his
system and fix an issue and the reason
that crib when people use the term Santa
it's become aware that people don't like
how that sounds judgey
but let's be clear sin is a spiritual
illness if you like going to a doctor
and a doctor wanting to fix you but he's
worried about actually diagnosing you
the doctor says like who well we can fix
you but oh my gosh what do we have to
fix well it's um it's something that's
like it's great it's growing it's a it's
a I don't I do I have cancer that's not
the word I want to use so it's gonna
make you say it's gonna make you sad
it's the same thing so when people say
sin like we need to address the sin we
need to recognize it as Christians but
we can all correct it and by the way
everyone is called to fix their own sin
yes we all have sin it's not a bad thing
but you need to be able to diagnose the
problem you need to be able to assess
the sin so that you can serve the sinner
otherwise they are held bondage to sin
for the rest of their life this is what
we've always believed as Christians yeah
and it's remarkable to me that that's
become a problem now because people
don't like to ever be reminded of the
fact that we're all sinners probably
send 20 times not that in this broadcast
just on this broadcast yeah well look it
goes back to you know going back to the
popularity and kind of serving the mob
we we understand that that's not what
we're supposed to do even if and we've
talked about the monetary side of this
if you're making your show brand
friendly so that you can get money even
if it costs you something the Bible
calls us to do what's right right and it
goes back to the story of Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego in Daniel 3:17 and
this is just it's one of my favorite
verses because these guys basically are
being called to bow down and worship
before this King Nebuchadnezzar and and
they say they basically like King we
can't do this and the King says that
he's going to throw them into the fiery
furnace and then it picks up in verse 17
it says look if it be so our God whom we
serve is able to deliver us from the
burning fiery furnace and he will
deliver us out of thy hand O king but it
then it goes on and says even if you
know you're not gonna do it going to do
transgender tutorial exactly right
that's exactly what it's saying like if
you if you have a line in the sand it
may cost you something short
so Shadrach Meshach and Abednego are
making the point we're not going to
serve you above our gut we're not going
to serve money above God we're not gonna
serve family above God we're not gonna
serve my job above God whatever it is
and even if it costs us something we're
willing to pay the price our God is able
to deliver us but even if he doesn't
we're still not gonna serve you right
and I know just kind of hear I think
they may actually believe that this is
sort of their if they've abandoned God
that this is their new God right
friendly that being said it's also
mighty convenient well there it is my
meaning that you work on YouTube and
you've happened to abandon the God in
the world view right that you thought
maybe would hold you back from appeasing
your new golden calf and you - right and
even if they don't think of it in those
terms effectively that is what it is
like you who do you serve will look at
your behaviors we don't talk about this
because of this we don't talk about that
because of this well that's who you
serve right you're serving YouTube
telling you those things and so what
what should we be doing Romans 12:2 do
not be conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
incredibly simple don't be conformed to
what this world does because they don't
know good from bad they don't know what
they're doing
yeah that's basically that verse is
saying YouTube they don't know what
they're doing yeah we're talking about
this being brand friendly and this sort
of crisis of faith and abandoning it and
changing and progressing let's kind of
go over the tangent to file benefits
what it's got on YouTube funded their
their half hour crypt descripted show
YouTube paid them to make their show
longer it was an experiment that didn't
really work out that well but every she
ate the creative risk now YouTube is
this is keep in mind oh by the way this
is the same company that sunk millions
of dollars into the young turks so let's
keep that in context sunk money into
rhettandlink and young turks by the way
we're still waiting for our YouTube
stimulus check they've won oh you got
all of a sudden really bless is this
church night on Apollo saying TD jakes
over there well actually he's probably
significantly wider than the voice did
they want show of the year
great most recent of the Streamy awards
that are of course put on by youtube
they presented the keynote address at
VidCon couple years back with YouTube
CEO Susan Wojcicki so it's paid it's
it's paid dividends
it is definitely paid with this this
very limited vertical that they've been
very clear it matters to them now and if
that were as fulfilling as the the
actual I guess sort of fulfilling your
purpose in how you were fearfully and
wonderfully created by God then it would
then it would be worthwhile yeah I don't
think that is the case and we'll get to
a clip afterward that that it sort of
implies that they don't think it's the
case and I don't begrudge them oh sorry
I don't know wait and I don't begrudge
them for being successful either
I know you don't at all it's in light of
all of these other things I think that's
why we're bringing this out and saying
look you guys you guys are just bowing
down to the garage being used as a
justification right it is that's what it
is for me I don't begrudge anyone being
successful i begrudge it when people use
it as justification for actions right
whether it's a successful government
that or you know what for example
wealthiest people in the world list what
is it i just mount thinking teenage Jake
something Slim's Carlos Slim's he's not
the wealthy he's one of them you have a
bunch of Saudi have a bunch of oil sort
of princes she's in the Middle East
that's not the same as a Jeff Bezos so
when people when we talk about this I
talk about it often I don't begrudge
Jeff Bezos at all for being wealthy I
have no problem with it because Amazon
has improved my life right I do begrudge
people who make that wealthiest list if
it's ill-gotten gain or if the
justification is well hey who are you to
criticize them look how rich they are
well I could also be rich if I simply
was born into a royal family that lived
on a plot of land that I raped the
wealth from all of its citizens now I
don't begrudge anyone for being
successful and I don't begrudge anyone
for making decisions that may be totally
in out of alignment with my own right i
begrudge people using success their
version of success as a justification
well and it is a big contrast between
their approach and your approach I mean
the reason that you've been able to
approach change you've been able to give
the metaphorical middle finger I don't
know if you've given them a literal one
but the metaphorical middle finger
where's Cupertino that's the spiritual
issue is giving the middle finger to
evil YouTube is that wrong yeah but the
reason you've been able to do that is
because you have a higher standard
outside of YouTube it sounds like the
way to get success in YouTube is to not
have any other standards yeah not have
any outside higher authority now I want
to be clear no people will look at that
say well actually you were demonetized
because you made fun of a gay cuban
mexican guy that's not well that's
actually not why and if you look at
Weber I we were obviously criticizing
Vox there's that word again
before and after and videos that
involved the gay gentleman in question
who called himself must be queer yes
where I came from and without
in question so I want to be really clear
that's not why and even then at that
point let's assume that that is wrong
you believe that's wrong let's assume
you believe it's wrong I am NOT going to
apologize because you believe it's wrong
for example when I say hey people who
cohabitate and I know there's a lot of
people out there and so you're gonna
feel I'm not judging you in the sense
that I think lesser of you I probably do
far worse things than that on a daily
basis but I am making the judgement that
the book I believe the god I serve says
you know what that's not that's not how
I want you to live because that's not
what will lead to a fruitful life I want
you to find a wife because I mean it
finds a wife finds what is good a women
I want you to be tender to your husband
submit to your husband's men love your
wives as Christ loved the church right
this is what I believe so when I say I'm
not going to apologize because you think
it's wrong I'm not going to apologize
because I say I don't think that two
guys and I said that's a Dave Rubin
getting hitched up the civil union fine
states can do that I supported I'm doing
that now I'm not gonna see that as the
same as a mom and a dad with kids
it's not the same relationship I don't
have to agree but I'm not going to
apologize because you think it's wrong
yeah because I don't think it's wrong
and that's what happened with YouTube I
don't think it's wrong I don't feel
convicted by it being wrong there's
nothing in my biblical worldview or
compass that tells me it's wrong and the
people primarily who are telling me it's
wrong are very often evil like right now
Google let's we can rattle it off they
have a history of working with Chinese
governments to censor information
suppress opposition n-b-c of course
we've Krita said they've been parroting
Chinese kovat propaganda points as of
late so when people who actually work
with governments that all of their
whistleblowers disappear when an entity
a company works with governments that
deny the sovereignty of a nation who
wanted to simply be free when they
decide to acquiesce them because it's
nice and brand friendly I think that's
evil and I won't apologize because in
evil world view knowing or knowingly or
not tells me I'm wrong yeah and I even
if I disagreed with you completely and
everything that you stood for I would
still be for you having a voice in a
channel right I may not want you to have
as big of a reach or I may want to make
counterpoints that are wrong that you're
saying or something like that feels
ready to do so well I'd have five people
on a channel we already love the lace
together I've people huh but what I'm
saying is that if you you end up kind of
building a box for yourself and then you
walk in and you close the door on
yourself when you allow YouTube and
other places like that to control what
you say because they're basically the
one person saying here is what's
acceptable for our society to have as an
idea right and you made a point about
this if you if you have kind of a
multinational company and you start
making the rules based on other
countries it gets even worse from there
and we saw this even with Facebook in
China with the social score and Facebook
being you know used to be able to help
them give people social scores to see if
they were supporting the party or not
like an episode of Black Mirror it's
it's just called real life
yeah the way and they you know that know
Miley Cyrus cameo the buyer says well no
I know Bryce Dallas Howard I never can
tell well and think of it this way in
this you know you always try not to say
something that's so inflammatory but
think of somebody in in Germany kind of
at the right time to be able to stand
and say wait a minute maybe maybe free
speech and saying that Jews aren't bad
people is not a bad thing it's the same
principle it may not be at the same
point in the process right but it's the
same principle if you allow one
organization to say you can't talk about
that you can't say these things are good
anymore and you go no no that's fine I'm
fine I'm gonna jump right in the middle
of this and just make money off your
system you become complicit in that
system to some degree it's the whole
time is if to dot if tomorrow YouTube
changes their policies and it's a
complete opposite of what Ren leaked
think what does that do to the retin
links
point of view or their worldview like if
all of a sudden they change absolutely
and I hope that people understand that
I've been absolutely fight for the right
just about a burp in my breath that
after having broadcast for 45 minutes
was trying to find its way which by the
way chick-fil-a has been slacking late
hit their drive-thru because they know
there's no competition yeah it's like
Bill Gates comers WagonR whacking tables
over my Microsoft Windows 98 it's the
only option two things remind me to go
back to the alt-right point that's in my
head because I don't have the best
short-term memory all right
YouTube has talked about this you know
it's a very difficult struggle to find
the balance between
sort of international different forms of
government and this is something they've
talked about openly and my worldview on
that my point of view is you have to go
with the laws and principles on the in
the country in which you were founded
the United States why here's why and
this is the problem of situational
ethics or what's the term that I'm
looking for now they don't use
situational ethics moral relativism yeah
I always learn situational ethics when I
was in school now it's more like a word
same thing but moral relativism if you
say well we have to strike a balance
well if you're trying to strike a
balance between different governments
who have wildly differing views on human
rights guess what it will always end up
debasing itself to the lowest common
denominator and what does that mean that
means that YouTube Google Twitter
Facebook take your pick zip tie me and
hand me over to the Pakistani government
so that I'm beheaded at a soccer game
because their official complaint from
the government of Pakistan I believe the
government of Pakistan the government of
Germany and the government of China for
violating hate speech laws yeah so you
have to either believe that free speech
is absolute and then it's not a right
that should ever be trampled on and you
shouldn't even design algorithms behind
the scenes to try and change that even
social interaction because you went into
the country that believes in those
values is the one that has made your
company valuable or
lowest-common-denominator zip-tie
everyone who said something offensive on
your platforms and hand them over to the
Sharks well under the laws of the
country in which Google was founded is
the reason that Google can exist yeah
right and can succeed and has free
speech is the reason they've been able
to grow as much as they have right the
reason YouTube exists and I think being
truthful this is something to what we
were talking while we're talking about
the idea of you know if it's popular
we've also experienced this in just the
conservative movement yeah I've never
been a member of the alt-right where
they sort of came and went and at some
point I was target numero uno listen I
wasn't a pro Trump guy in the primary
and I wasn't pro Trump honestly for the
first few first few months his
presidency and then there were some
turnarounds - I'm actually pretty
impressed with this guy I haven't run
from it I've been pretty open about it
and there was a time a point in time
where when we weren't doing Pepe memes
and weren't just being edge lords online
or you know doing the some of it wasn't
a huge percentage by the way of people
in the conservative movement but
unfortunately they dominated the
conversation quite
and made it very difficult for us to go
out and create content and there were
there was a period in time where we
thought you know what this is a new
conservative and it's not me no we
didn't go along with it we still haven't
gone along with it and you know what
we're still here standing and you can
look at the through line and see that we
have all been yeah if it's not
consistent because views do change
sometimes certainly at the very least I
guess you would say you know where we
stand and you know why we've changed
yeah point of view and there are very
few point of views that I'm honestly
changed with some people some people see
as a bad thing it means you're
inflexible I don't know I mean of course
you're gonna learn and grow over time
but you're not gonna flip-flop on issues
like a politician would just a gain
voter popularity right that's the the
biggest can and so I want to go back to
their their process right and they're
thinking you know yeah well there is I
would never say that but of leaving
leaving the faith you know the Bible
talks about it when it talks about the
term denotes likes someone nailing some
kind of a Roman right entering in yeah I
might want to turn I'm looking for right
now the people would have nailed the
Roman not Centurion is if I'm looking
for soldier that's an Amex Roman
soldiers that's a card kneeling in a
cross being like you know we're not
calling us nailing anymore they're
calling this metal fun times just
rewarding it semester great construction
you know you are turning your back on
Christ which right makes a father who
loves you very very sad so I don't want
to use that language because I think it
diminishes and I know that you were
using because it diminishes the
magnitude of what it is right as an old
word is about apostasy yes it's just not
very you know used any mooseville so
really what happened is common right in
the in Bible talks about the peril of
the soap so are basically where seed
ends up in good ground but root you know
weeds quickly come up and choke it out
right and I think what we saw with
rhettandlink more I have to guess I'm
not judging I'm not saying that this is
100 percent accurate but it's kind of a
story common to man they went out to
someplace else they went out to Los
Angeles to chase after a
and there's nothing wrong with that you
went out there you pursued a career but
then you started chasing after something
more than you chased after God you
started chasing after what people
thought what people felt how you felt
about how they felt about you and all of
the things that come with that and you
started chasing after something more
than God and you ended up leaving your
faith that's really what I say Morgado
is that chasing after something other
than God yeah well more meaning you
spent more time chasing after that than
God because I don't originate Lee left
but they started putting something above
God whether they meant to or not right
and eventually it created such a chasm
that they're like well wait a minute
maybe I don't really believe this
anymore
maybe that foundation that I thought I
had I didn't really actually have well
they would they would argue that the
whole process started when they were
back in North Carolina but didn't start
when they're in LA but you've made that
point I don't know that that's and I
think that's probably true in the sense
that these were probably people who
eventually if the right person came
around would abandon their faith anyway
sure well they thrust themselves into an
environment seeking to be a part of that
club the forces want to abandon their
faith
right yeah they they moved from North
Carolina to LA LA didn't take them away
yeah yeah yeah and I moved to Los
Angeles and you turned that okay well no
I left remember I was very I was it was
a crisis of faith for me in the sense
that I remember the men of my
countenance leaping out of Seymour's a
renovated apartment up on the top floor
where I auditioned I refused to audition
for a film and I was like a lifetime
film or basically was a good woman down
a flight of stairs I would have done
just because I believe this is iconic
I'm seeing no it was like a gay scene
where I was basically like having
fellatio performed in a truck stop and
it was pretty graphic and I said I just
I don't feel I don't feel comfortable
doing this and I keep in mind that just
I think I audition not long earlier for
like a scene that would require me
streaking I'm like fine I don't care
there's nothing wrong with this is not
titillating my agent at this point said
well you know what I'm never gonna be
able to work together if you refuse to
work blue I said this is it's literally
blowing a guy at a truck stop on
television I just don't want to do this
like it's not like I'm not eliminating
everything I'm pretty lenient which to
to
to my everlasting shame sometimes when
this hate and I and I really reject
where I said I said this I spoke my
parents I was like this is something
what do you do this was for me this was
a very and then maybe this is what
strikes close to home for the same
reason that they call me a piece of but
what if I were to say oh that lesbian
produced your pieces yeah oh because
it's in a press class it's the same
language actly it's just that it's okay
it's brand friendly to say this guy even
though the truth is it's a minority
viewpoint on YouTube by design but this
wasn't is my not crisis of faith that
you can call it that was when I had and
I lived in New York and I done stand-up
and I got anything just for last
festival and I'd done a few films at
this point I'd done Arthur I did a lot
of commercials and I was in Los Angeles
and I had this conversation with an
agent and there was a point where I
realized haunting everything that I ever
thought that I wanted which was just to
either do stand-up participation Elector
I don't know that I can do this since
that I don't know that I want to do this
anymore I remember telling my dad I just
I don't know that I'll ever play well
with others when the others are these
people right in this state in this
industry I don't know that I can do it
and that's when I went back to stay with
my family for a little bit and I
actually said give me six months because
well you have to get a job if we're not
gonna be in Los Angeles and I had left a
film set that was called to save a life
in Oceanside California was a Christian
film but it was the only Christian
product I've ever been a part of yeah
could have gone back to Los Angeles I
understand lined up and said I drove
back to my family because I wanted
nothing to do with that industry at that
point and unfortunately also sometimes
working with Christians in the industry
you have a little bit of a blast of cold
water yeah um my family's okay if you're
not gonna do it then you better start
doing stand-up and what you know
stand-up more when you're here start
working us it gave me six months let me
try the YouTube thing I think I can do
this and the second I came out with more
conservative leanings I'm a manager
dropped me as well all of these cards
just came tumbling down and thank God
thank and I mean this I mean thank God
thank Christ I don't mean that an Irish
gotta thank thank Christ that there were
some companies that came by there was a
TV at the time in Fox News and Dennis
Miller at that point it was Dennis
Miller Michelle Malkin Andrew Breitbart
and Sean Hannity Neil Cavuto were the
people who kind of took me under their
wing and had me on their shows here's a
guy who's relative alan colmes to his
credit yeah who had me on the shows to
express my point of view because
unique enough and I said oh maybe I can
do this but I would have had to accept
the fact that everything I'd worked for
I wasn't going to be able to do because
I had to face myself unless I can't work
in this industry right what this stage
of my life and it you had worked in that
industry since you were a kid
this wasn't spent a lot of time being
tutored on set yeah this wasn't
something that you just kind of picked
up later in life and said I'll give this
a try this was like your lifelong
aspiration right this is what you wanted
to do and I remember kind of early on in
our friendship like there were plenty of
opportunities for you to go this is just
not worth it like I'm swimming against
the grain so much that it would have
been very easy and recurrent against the
current going across those metaphors
mixed metaphors I guess so you can you
know you've crossed the grains you
turned your leafs and the tree and
things yeah but you very easily yeah you
could have very easily walked away or
you know said I'm not going to really
participate in conservative media
anymore and I'm just gonna have a
viewpoint that's much more Center so
I'll get a lot more well that was you
know you know that with conservative
media I had some rowdy monster oh yes
and I didn't blame the ideals and I
certainly didn't blame the Christian
exactly I understood that this was a
byproduct of an imperfect interpretation
or application by man yeah and that's
what I remember the last time the last
time that I remember crying as a man
outside of like a death or was in a
conservative company which shall remain
nameless I think you guys know where
they had me working there full-time for
a long while
and was really angling for a contract
and they said yeah I mean I met up with
them at this point I was married and
they said but you're gonna do it for
free I'm gonna do for the exposure we're
not gonna pay you know and I was at a
crepe place with my parents and I
remember just sitting I had to leave
great like crepe place I don't even need
crepes this is how I remember it
and I just left and I walked out and I
kind of knelt down behind a dumpster and
I'm just like just that kind of like a
[ __ ] just sobbing because I had been
doing in five weeks full-time and I
thought I was moving towards something
and it was just pulled off the table and
I had a good friend at that time we
didn't even go in to bat for me who knew
it was wrong and I my dad just said hey
we're at this point this was a guy said
you better start working yeah and I said
give me six months I'll do the YouTube
thing at this point I was a flipper he
said hey you don't need them do your own
thing and that was the moment where I
got the rights to this show and I know
listen this isn't it's not like this is
some
some unbelievable you know hallmark film
success case but I am grateful for what
we have and I'm able to make a living
and everyone here is able to make a
living and it's blessed a lot of people
and I consider it very much a blessing
to me and my dad said you don't need
them you can do this and he said and I
know I believe in you and at that point
I've always tried to draw closer to God
and I'm not very the reason I want to be
clear too about this and I want to go
back and you guys can wrap up because
you make much better points than I do
the reason we didn't do math Monday for
a long time and I've always been very
open about my faith but I didn't feel
comfortable doing this kind of a format
is because I am NOT an expert at all
like I said I've read through the Bible
multiple times because I had a one year
bible unto church I've been a part of a
small group I do it devotional every day
but I when I I love sitting at the feet
of experts in anything that's where you
see when I sit down with Daniel Cormier
or someone like a champion the show in
fighting just athletics like oh my god
her Brian Shaw I was a strong man even
though I don't follow strong names like
I just want to sit here and listen
Thomas so like oh I wanna sit and absorb
everything that's the same way I am with
theology in issues of God and I know
that I'm not in authority I'm not
claiming to be an authority so I've
always been very uncomfortable until
someone who worked here said hey you
know what he was sort of a Christian we
know smooth smooth Manny but not really
and said like this has helped me and
it's actually good to see very imperfect
people yeah taking us and that's all
this is this is very imperfect people
who do not claim to be experts at all
taking a stand for what we believe is
right in spite of it maybe not being
very popular yeah and really just having
a conversation about this knowing that
it could cost us you know knowing that
it could be an unpopular opinion to to
say something like hey we just don't
think rhettandlink story really lines up
with with reality a lot of times right
now there could be blowback from that we
understand that but at some point
there's a there's you mean like being
called a piece of what the memes where
they talked about after I I've only seen
Oh watch and I really I will I just
don't want to contribute to the don't
watch and I want to be clear no problem
with that well then they're right I saw
the right I bought a figured anyway I
have I have a segment called what a
piece is and we've applied it both to
Don Lemon in times right well as the
World Health Organization
casting any stones yeah it's okay if you
cast some stones at us just just back it
up you should hit me with a boulder no
no right you should push a button and an
Acme anvil just bonk I'm finally and I
know you said it on the show but it was
hilarious before the show she was like
yeah she called me a piece of [ __ ] was
like oh man he goes no no it's totally
fine I'm just curious why you weren't
curious like I want to know why you're
like I'm just curious like which things
she thinks made me a piece of that I
said and I think we have we have what
another trainer did you have any points
you wanted to make there yeah I was just
gonna say that what you were just
talking about is an illustration of why
you should stick to your principles and
and not just principles broadly but the
truth and why knowing that you're
committed to the truth is the most
important thing and not just finding
some organization or some company and
saying whatever your loyalties are those
are my loyalties it's actually having
standards outside of some kind of
corporate loyalty that makes you good it
makes you good for these platforms or
not and then that's much more important
well the truth right now is there some
sort of a tugboat
duck things that has the wheels near an
airport every now and then well no I
mean the the philosophy that you said
Wade it's not like we're just espousing
this because it's good for faith think
about yourself in this really not good
enough use right think about this like
bucking bucking culture and bucking
trends what if you're in an office where
it's it's acceptable within that office
all the guys to do sexually
inappropriate things to women right to
grab them and to say things and you're
like oh I'll just go along to get along
kind of thing no you had to stand up you
have to have a backbone you have to have
principles that apply in all parts of
your life we're not all perfect we're
not always gonna stand up when we should
and hopefully we'll kick our own butt
and go you know what next time I'm gonna
say something I'm gonna intervene I'm
gonna do the right thing whatever it is
this applies to every part of your life
if you have no standards if you have no
spine and no backbone you will just let
anything happen and we don't want that
for anybody we don't want people to be
sexually assaulted at work or harassed
at work we don't want any situation like
that we also don't want people to kind
of curtail their speech because they
think yeah that this is the popular
thing I say and this actually brings me
back in it
kind of brings me full circle back to
the point of view that I have changed
and people you can go back and you can
see this is actually I think from our
very first show ever that might have
been a very first live show that was I
believe at Virginia Tech see the
Virginia Tech where SNU compared to U of
M or a.m. where people asked about hey
I'm in an industry where everyone is
very liberal or people say you know what
a ministry what should I do
and my answer used to be listen if you
have like Gary Sinise money or
Bruckheimer money let your freak flag
fly and if not I can understand keeping
your head down and hoping to get to a
position where you can influence people
for the better so I can understand being
sound and keep me if you want to keep
your mouth shut
that's okay with me and I've changed
that ouch in that response and because
at first I thought I was offering an
answer and I thought well you know what
I can't sort of copy-paste myself in
that situation because I know that I
wouldn't be happy don't yeah I know that
wouldn't be able to do it but if some
people can and then I realized that
people are going to smell it on you
anyway
and that's if it's if it's your
political worldview or if it's your
worldview as seen through the lens of
faith people will smell it on you anyway
and I don't believe that anyone whose
fundamental principles and this is why
now I say you got to just be honest
about it be open with it and you know
we've always said we can't maybe you're
not a shark but you can be a puffer fish
you can be a porcupine you can be the
poison dart frog where they just really
wish they hadn't tried to take a bite
here because I feel really sick I think
that anyone who's whose convictions
truly mean anything or defined them
could not feel good about themselves or
happy in putting their head down and
keeping quiet as long as it advanced
them career-wise until they got to a
point where they feel that they could
speak up because you never really get to
that point because there's always
another no in that ladder and so that is
a viewpoint that has changed just
because I have seen so many and you can
take a who's who of people who've been
successful in this movement and fallen
or some people who've become successful
through modifying their worldviews when
you change your fundamental worldview
when you change your principles your
foundational principles as an appeal to
popularity as a spiritual argument or an
intellectual argument it true not only
does it not hold water but it leaves you
empty and it leaves you unhappy
and it just takes different people a
different time line to admit it and
figure it out and that's why we're doing
math Monday and that's why we're talking
about this and the idea of being brand
safe and popular if that's a part of a
Christian worldview because it's not
it's never been and you can look at the
founder of the feast Jesus Christ
himself
he was never liked by everyone he was
hated by more people than he was loved
and I think at the end of this when you
look at what their worldview is
rhettandlink and I would have really
welcomed them on the show and we'd keep
it up as respectful and speaking love
you look at what they've done how
they've benefited but you also have to
look at what it has cost and I think
this is a pretty candid clip right here
from rhett and Link that's sort of
crystallizes that whatever it is that
we're that we are right now I call
myself a hopeful agnostic right now but
I don't have the structure or the
community or the singular sort of
well-defined purpose that I did and that
is now that's a problem I'm not trying
to paint that listen it's not like I'm
about to give you some philosophy that I
live according to now that's got get the
gives that gives me community purpose
and meaning I don't have that okay I
think there's a giant sort of shift
that's happening culturally and I think
that we may be arriving at that some
time but it doesn't exist right now for
me but what does exist is an openness is
this curiosity I guess our Christianity
has this boat in a very stormy sea it's
stable there's a lot of other people on
it it's got a destination you're gonna
get through this it gives you something
to hold on to it gives you stability it
gives you purpose it gives you direction
and it gives you community and when I
jump ship I didn't jump to another boat
I jumped into the water
and I pulled my wife and my children or
you jumped into a boat with holes in it
I jumped into a sea of uncertainty
and that's where I've lived for about
six years but what happened to all that
community and the people who cause you
to jump ship and you became a part of
this cool kid social club at YouTube the
streamys not made anything the keynote
address does not mean anything the
launches with Susan Wojcicki not mean
anything being Brant having 1,700 videos
from your own admission that none of
which are brand unfriendly then I mean
anything how is how is that a sea of
uncertainty and not just another boat
I'm confused I live with this Luke 9:25
for what does it profit a man if he
gains the whole world and loses himself
and that's why we've tried to take this
on and do our best job possible for a
bunch of a bunch of YouTube hacks
without their podcast I hope it's been
insightful illuminating or served you
well we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]